all right everybody what's going on the
rowdy crowd Disneyland I love it more
than any time now is the time to give
back to these courageous kids who really
inspire us
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the thing that I have loved so much
about being part of the beginning of
this new chapter is the ability to
inspire others but the thing is is the
kids that are here today are actually
the ones that inspire us we're also
blessed and grateful and touched to be a
part of this group but to meet so many
of you and to be able to give something
back you've given us so much more
meeting the kids around the world and
their families and siblings going
through these situations that the true
heroes and a true inspiration for us and
it is a real privilege to be inspired by
them and say thank you very much for
that I would like to say the ant-man
toys are particularly small so when
you're walking around barefoot just be
careful it's a it's a little bit like
stepping on a lego I mean just feel
really really lucky to be here and also
to be able to provide you know kids that
are ill spend so much of their time you
know really dealing with serious stuff
that you know kids just should not have
to deal with and nobody should have to
deal with and I think just being able to
provide any opportunity for kids to do
exactly what they do best just be a kid
is awesome so feel really really
privileged to be any part of that today
I think that to me could I take him out
here for us and until they could and I
felt like I was about to cry it's so
cool it's so great to come and feed a
bunch of kids come on man this is a
great way to start any day
[Music]
my favorite part is when we got to get
the Lego figures that was like the best
thing ever had in my life
it was exciting and amazing fantastic it
was Disneyland and meeting these
wonderful kids this is always a pretty
special thing yeah sometimes you have to
explain me like who use like Thor the
like where's the hammer and the long
hair and the outfitting but I think it
gives you incredible and looked at
they're an inspiration for us you know I
know that this these characters bring a
little joy to young kids around the
world but you know the reason I think
most of us do it is is is that that yeah
that looks on their faces when I do see
these movies or they talk to you about
them
[Music]